Hunter Biden is officially dating his  sister-in-law Holly Hollies late husband  Hunter's brother Beau Biden died in May  2016 after battling brain cancer hunter  who reportedly separated from his wife  Kathleen before beau died confirmed the  relationship in a statement to page six  quote Holly and I are incredibly lucky  to have found the love and support we  have for each other in such a difficult  time and that's been obvious to the  people who love us most former Vice  President Joe Biden and his wife Jill  have reportedly given the couple their  blessing Joe told page six quote we are  all lucky that hunter and Holly found  each other as they were putting their  lives together again after such sadness  [Music]